MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, I'm
Martin Omander, and today
I'll tell you about a pain point
from my previous developer jobs
and how to solve it
with modern technology.
I wished I'd had this
technology back then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before my current job as a
Developer Advocate at Google,
I worked at a string of
startups as a software engineer.
I always struggled
with how to store
passwords, API
keys, certificates,
and other sensitive data.
If I hardcoded these secrets
into the source code,
I had two problems.
One, anyone with access
to the source repo
could see the secrets.
They could copy the
secret somewhere else,
and we didn't have auditing
and access controls.
And two, it would be hard to
move code between dev, test,
and production environments.
Secrets typically differ
between environments.
So in my previous job, I did
what the Twelve-Factor App
methodology recommends.
I put the secrets in
environment variables.
That way they were not
part of the code base.
But the secrets had
to be stored somewhere
so I put them in a file,
which I had to be careful
not to check into
source control.
At one job, we burned
secrets to a CD
that we kept in the
CIO's desk drawer.
Handling files without
source control is awkward.
I remember thinking
that there must
be a better way of doing it.
Secret Manager and
Google Cloud platform
provides that better way.
It has been generally
available since March 2020.
We recently added
native integration
with Cloud Run, which makes
it easy to mount secrets
in Cloud Run services.
Let's see how we can update
an existing Cloud Run
service to use Secret Manager.
The service is a
simple API that returns
information about different
dog breeds, like this.
The code reads database,
user, password, et cetera,
from environment variables
when it creates the database
connection pool here.
The environment
variables are shown here
in the Cloud Console
in plaintext.
So let's say we want a
better control and auditing
of the database password by
moving it into Secret Manger.
We see here that the Cloud
Run servers runs as Dog Breed
API, a custom service account.
I used the principle
of least privilege
when I created this
account, so it only
has the Cloud SQL client role.
This means that it can
connect to Cloud SQL
databases but nothing else.
We will need to remember this
account for the next step.
Next, I will go to the
Secret Manager in my project,
create a new secret for
the database password,
and enter its value here.
Now, let's see who can
access this password.
The Dog Breed API is
not in the list yet.
Let's add it.
Again, we're applying the
principle of least privilege.
The Dog Breed API
account currently
has access to db_password, but
not any of the other secrets
that we see here.
This reduces risk.
Now, I'm ready to go back
to the Cloud Run service.
First, I remove the DB_PASS
plaintext environment variable.
I feel better already.
Then, I'll add it
back, but instead
of entering the
actual password, I
will point DB_PASS to the
password in Secret Manager.
Then I click DEPLOY here so
this change takes effect.
And look, the API still works.
So, what did we achieve here?
Well first, we can now use the
principle of least privilege
for the password
and other secrets.
We can define
granular permissions
for who can access which secrets
and who can add new secrets.
For example, we
just configured it
so our Cloud Run service
can access, but not write,
db_password in production.
And if only a few
people in our dev team
are allowed to handle
secrets in production,
we reduce the risk of downtime
due to silly mistakes.
I know.
I once mistakenly deleted
the production database
at a previous job.
Second, we now have
auditing of this password.
By default, whenever it
is created or updated
we'll get a log entry like this.
I usually also turn
on additional logging
so there will be an
entry for whenever
a secret is accessed as well.
And we achieved all
this without changing
a single line of source code.
Delightful.
But what if our existing
code reads secrets
from a file instead of
environment variables?
No problem.
We can configure Cloud Run so
that secrets look like files
to the source code.
Pretty neat.
I should also mention there is
a third way of accessing secrets
from source code.
Our code could make a call
to the Secret Manager client
library every time
it needs a secret.
This obviously means that we
have to update our source code,
but every time we call
the client library
we will get the current
value of the secret.
So this method is useful if we
expect secrets to change often
and we don't want to redeploy
our Cloud Run servers
every time that happens.
The same is true when we
read secrets as a file.
If we access secrets as
environment variables
and we update a secret, we
need to redeploy the Cloud Run
service to get the latest
value of that secret.
This has been an
introduction to using
Cloud Run with Secret Manager.
The docs have a lot
more information,
like best practices for
how to manage permissions,
how to rotate your
secrets to reduce risk,
and how to version secrets.
Also, in the
description below, you
will find a link to
the source code I used.
I really hope that
this makes it easier
for you to build secure systems.
As developers, our
code may be entrusted
with some very sensitive data.
We carry a big responsibility.
Let's live up to it.
Please let me know if
this video was helpful
or if you have any questions.
Also, if you have
suggestions for new episodes,
please add them in
the comments below.
Until next time.